welcome to sims and left go everybody
we're not in the studio and we're
dressed like oh hey what up Valerie to
see you and this who is this is jolly
old st. Nick
show who you are big reveal oh there is
we're back with the main man himself Sam
darn old and we're here at the
Livingston mall today it's not Santa
Claus that's what I'm looking at it's
Santa Claus
[Music]
oh ho ho Oh Vanna we got Joey here Oh
five buddy Oh tell me what you want for
Christmas this year
oh that's a great game I've heard from
all the kids what do you guys want for
Christmas this year
a puppy surprise and you're a Nerf ball
a nerf gun we definitely have a lot we
are a lot of those we do Santa we got
Steven here Oh Oh Steven what do you
want for Christmas this year
se Kwang Barkley Jersey what do you want
for Christmas this year
say Kwan do you watch football who's
your favorite team hey buddy what's your
name Blake good to meet you oh I like it
right here like oh yeah that's a really
cool Jersey you got on there who's your
favorite player on the Jets Lord Jamal I
think maybe one day you'll be able to
meet one of those guys maybe next year
though he's your cousin that's cool
good family cool his name we've had yet
Santa what is it Chris I like that name
kind of what do you want for Christmas
is to your buddy
a skateboard do you like the Jets yeah
so Santa used to play football at North
Pole High School and we want him to
throw you a pass a little bit further
than that
off target yeah yeah you had to go up
and get that one didn't you we were
wondering if anyone wanted to catch
passes from Santa Claus
see what you got Santa Santa can really
throw you got it on the way yeah
the reindeer told me that it's time for
you to go to the bathroom
no girl yes it is I know Santa's got to
go the bathroom fan I can't hold it in I
[Music]
don't know what happened to Santa but
his friend came and I want you to meet
him okay
I want to introduce you to the starting
quarterback of the New York Jets
oh thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]